Traduttore: Laura Pillon
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Sono Berardo,
il cuoco di corte di Federico II.
Vivo a Melfi, nel Castello di Melfi,
e mi sposto anche in altri castelli
per cucinare per l'imperatore
e per i suoi commensali.
Sto andando dritto verso Oria,
ma non mi fermo a Castel del Monte,
perché Castel del Monte non ha cucina.
Castel del Monte è stato dedicato
più all'arte delle stelle
che non a me.
Io passo oltre,
vado a Oria, mi fermo a Lucera,
mando i miei fidi a fare incetta
di pesce al Lago di Lesina
mentre aspetto che il mio imperatore
mi porti la sua cacciagione.
Il mio imperatore ama moltissimo
i piccioni col miele, arrostiti,
oppure altri tipi di cacciagione.
Non ama molto il cinghiale:
la carne di cinghiale è una carne dura,
è una carne fibrosa,
è una carne senza grassi.
Io non gliela cucino quasi mai.
Nel frattempo, però, faccio preparare
dei formaggi straordinari,
fatti dai casari lì vicino,
formaggi come le mozzarelle,
come i caciocavalli
– caciocavalli ricavati dal latte delle
mucche portate dall'Ucraina,
le nostre podoliche –
formaggi di erbe freschi.
Non ama il pecorino:
il pecorino è un formaggio duro,
un formaggio dal sapore forte
e noi lo diamo ai cani, agli animali.
Non lo mangiamo volentieri
nella nostra corte.
Però la cosa più bella che abbia fatto
il nostro imperatore
è stato portare alla nostra corte
altri popoli.
Allora dovetti industriarmi,
dovetti studiare le cucine
degli altri popoli nostri ospiti.
Ero abituato a cucinare cacciagione,
pollame.
Arrivarono gli ebrei,
arrivarono i musulmani,
arrivarono altri popoli
e io dovetti studiare.
Per lui inventai un piatto
che sicuramente nei secoli a venire
sarebbe stato usato: l'escapecia.
Ho creato l'escapecia facendo bollire
pesci in aceto.
L'aceto nostro, quello che noi facciamo,
è l'agresto:
sono chicchi di uva spremuti
a mano,
poi bolliti con la calanga,
con lo zenzero,
con i chiodi di garofano
e con qualche spicchio d'aglio.
Nelle mie cucine faccio
pulire questi pesci,
faccio togliere le spine
e li avvolgo in piccoli lenzuolini
di seta o di cotone.
Li avvolgo uno a uno,
perché c'è un motivo.
Il mio imperatore è un imperatore magro,
io, invece, sono un cuoco opulento,
però per questo stiamo bene insieme.
Lui ama quello che io gli cucino,
lui ama me e tutta la mia corte,
perché gli faccio mangiare cose nuove,
ogni volta.
La cucina non si ripete,
si evolve con i popoli.
Io ho capito questo
attraverso la sua cultura
e cerco di trasformare i prodotti
in più modi.
Tornando all'escapecia,
prendo questi pesci,
li metto in teglie grosse
e li cospargo di agresto
bollente e pieno di spezie.
Chiudo con un coperchio
e faccio macerare il tutto
per due giorni.
Dopo lo porto a tavola condito solo
con dell'olio crudo.
A lui piace molto questo tipo di cucina,
perché è una cucina leggera, ma nutriente.
Ne ha bisogno il mio imperatore,
perché il mio imperatore dalle guerre
torna a casa, ritorna nei suoi castelli
con la gotta,
perché mangia solo carne arrosto.
Io ho bisogno di depurare l'organismo
del mio imperatore.
Gli preparo biscotti con il miele,
che a lui piace moltissimo,
oppure lo zucaro,
ma lo zucaro è abbastanza grezzo,
è troppo forte,
allora lui preferisce il miele
dappertutto:
sulla carne, sui biscotti, sul pane
– il pane fatto con farine dure,
farine nere,
farine integrali, farine di miglio,
farine di orzo.
Questo è il nostro cibo nel Medioevo,
che io accompagno poi con gli ottimi vini
che trovo nelle mie campagne del Vulture,
come l'Ellenico o come la Malvasia,
o come il Greco, con il quale mi porto
più avanti, verso l'Irpinia.
La Capitanata è una zona molto bella
e la Puglia dall'altra parte mi conforta
con i suoi grandi orti,
con le sue grandi pianure,
dove posso coltivare le erbe,
con cui faccio poi delle crostate,
dei pasticci.
È tutto buono in Apulia,
è tutto buono in Capitanata
e per me il gioco è molto più semplice,
è molto più facile.
Mi spingo fin verso Tursi,
dove i miei amici Saraceni hanno costruito
tre rabatane sparse nei nostri territori:
una nell'attuale Tursi,
l'altra a Tricarico
e l'altra ancora vicino a Potenza.
Le rabatane sono dei luoghi
dove i Saraceni hanno creato
il loro "rabat",
i loro incontri,
e hanno portato in dono alle nostre terre
quello stupendo frutto che è l'arancio,
il portogallo.
Ancora ci sono delle tracce
di portogalli antichi nelle nostre terre.
A Tursi per esempio c'è la staccia,
un tipo di arance grossissime
che a volte pesano addirittura
tra i 300 e i 500 grammi l'una
e che i miei amici saraceni mangiavano
a fette con la cannella e lo zucchero
e di cui buttavano via le bucce.
Gli abitanti del luogo
raccoglievano le bucce,
le bollivano in acqua dolce
e così crearono il gileppo.
Per non farlo mangiare ai musulmani
lo friggevano con il maiale,
perché il maiale per noi il maiale
era importante,
ma i musulmani non lo mangiavano.
In seguito avevamo paura anche
dei cristiani che passavano
e che se avessero visto le arance
avrebbero pensato
che fossimo tutti musulmani.
Allora prendevamo le teste dei maiali
e le mettevano alla finestra
con un'arancia in bocca
per dire: "Guardate, qui siamo cristiani,
perché mangiamo il maiale.
Non siamo musulmani,
anche se abbiamo le arance".
Questi sono racconti e le storie
che si perpetuano nei secoli.
Federico II ci portò tantissime arti,
dall'astronomia alla cultura
più in generale.
Lui era lo Stupor Mundi.
Ma ci lasciò anche tantissime,
bellissime e ottime pietanze
che noi nei secoli,
in questa nostra piccola regione,
abbiamo contribuito a conservare.
La Basilicata è una regione arcaica,
è una regione antica.
Con questa sua arcaicità oggi
può diventare una nicchia,
uno scrigno di profumi,
di sapori e di tradizioni,
perché ogni piccolo paese,
ogni piccolo villaggio,
come dicevano loro,
mantiene intatte
delle tradizioni incredibili,
legate a eventi cosmici, a eventi
della natura e ad eventi attuali.
La Basilicata è straordinaria,
perché conserva queste grandi tradizioni.
A volte racconto di questi grandi eventi
legati alla resurrezione della natura,
come quando prendiamo tre elementi
e li mettiamo insieme
per fare un unico piatto:
l'uovo, il formaggio e il verde.
L'uovo è il simbolo della cosmicità,
del cosmo,
perché dentro l'uovo ci sono
i quattro elementi della natura:
il fuoco è il tuorlo,
l'acqua è l'albume,
l'aria è la roccia, la terra.
L'uovo si schiude ed esce fuori la vita.
Prendiamo l'uovo, lo leghiamo al formaggio
– alla toma, al casieddu
o a qualunque altro tipo di formaggio
che noi siamo bravissimi
a fare da secoli –
e lo leghiamo al formaggio,
perché il formaggio è il simbolo
di verginità, purezza, catarsi
– noi ci purifichiamo attraverso il cibo –
e lo leghiamo insieme al verde.
Il verde è la terra, l'amara terra,
e può essere il finocchietto,
il cardoncello, i piselli,
qualunque cosa che sia verde.
Noi li mettiamo insieme in primavera.
Poi il Cristianesimo li riprese
e li portò il giorno di Pasqua.
Anche dopo la fine del Medioevo,
Federico II lasciò tante tracce di sé,
ma tutto cambiò in cucina.
Con il Rinascimento
arrivarono altri prodotti,
arrivarono altri ingredienti:
i peperoni, le patate, i pomodori,
i peperoncini.
Cambiò tutta la cucina.
Noi abbiamo ancora
grandi tradizioni gastronomiche
che possiamo conservare,
che possiamo offrire
come un grande scrigno innovativo
alle nuove cucine,
riprendendo il vecchio,
quello che avevamo,
se per vecchio si intende
l'arte della conservazione.
Noi abbiamo una regione straordinaria,
che può assurgere
all'attenzione universale
proprio come contenitore di arcaicità,
dell'antico conservatosi fino a oggi.
Le nostre ricette sono intrise di sudore,
sicuramente,
ma sono intrise di racconti,
di favole, di quotidianità.
Le nostre ricette raccontano i tempi.
Così come chi è cristiano ricorderà
che Gesù raccontava le sue esperienze
attraverso il cibo.
Il cibo come mezzo di comunione,
il cibo come mezzo di comunicazione.
La cosa più incredibile
è che uno dei primi mezzi di comunicazione
è stato proprio il cibo.
Parlando attraverso il cibo
si uniscono le persone,
intorno a una tavola si comunicava.
Oggi abbiamo l'Ipad,
però una volta si comunicava di più
stando seduti attorno a una tavola.
Qui le famiglie si sedevano
e parlavano, raccontavano,
poi la sera si trasferivano
vicino al calore del camino
e continuavano a parlare e raccontare
per finire la serata
con un bicchiere di vino e una frisella.
Ecco il cibo
come comunione e comunicazione.
Il cibo non è solo ciò che noi mangiamo,
non è solo ciò che noi ingeriamo.
Il cibo è vita,
perché quando noi siamo
nella pancia della mamma,
della nostra genitrice, ci nutriamo.
Quando nasciamo,
non diciamo: "Ciao mamma, sono uscito!
Come stai?"
Ci accostiamo al suo seno e ci nutriamo.
Più ci nutriamo e più cresciamo.
Una volta che è finito
il nostro ciclo della vita,
noi stessi diventiamo cibo.
Questo è il grande ciclo della vita,
di cui fa parte anche il cibo.
Immaginate la ricchezza culturale
che una regione come la nostra possiede:
pur essendo una regione piccolissima,
con i suoi 130 comuni,
vanta 130 esperienze diverse,
grazie a tutti i popoli
che ci hanno visitato,
che per andare da nord a sud, da oriente
a occidente, sono passati di qua.
È un amplificatore delle tradizioni,
la Basilicata.
Facciamo della nostra regione,
della nostra Basilicata,
una grande identità, andando
a riscoprire queste grandi tradizioni,
da Federico II a tutti gli altri
che pian piano stiamo riscoprendo.
Immaginate la ricchezza, oggi,
della proiezione innovativa
di una regione antica.
Probabilmente Berardo,
parlando del suo imperatore,
aveva davvero ragione quando disse che,
se il Dio degli Ebrei avesse conosciuto
le terre dell'Apulia e della Capitanata,
probabilmente non avrebbe fatto
della Palestina la Terra Promessa.
Grazie.
(Applausi)